good morning Hank it's Tuesday October
14th well the nerdfighters have voted
about whether or not you should be
punished for putting up your videos
slightly late yesterday and the
consensus seems to be no but Hank you
seem to have forgotten one small detail
it's not up to the nerdfighters to
decide whether or not you get punished
for breaking the rules it's up to me and
I agree with them you're a good brother
and you shouldn't be punished oh hi
there Margo I didn't think you'd be
making an appearance in today's video
Margaret Iams when we're this close
together I feel like you might try to
kiss me and then be weird because the
Yeti and the age difference and the fact
that you were a fictional character that
I created so just gonna tell you right
now it's not gonna work between us so
Hank I think for my next couple videos
I'm gonna read from my new book Paper
Towns which comes out on Thursday I'm
going to start by reading the prologue
which some nerdfighters will remember I
read several months ago but it was very
different then so maybe it'll be an
insight into the world of revision oh
and I'm totally going to go over four
minutes but I'm going to get around it
by using a montage okay so Paper Towns
starts out with two epigraphs one of
which is from a poem written by a
nerdfighter Katrina Vandenberg then we
turn a couple pages and the prologue the
way I figured everyone gets a miracle
like I'll probably never be struck by
lightning
or win a Nobel Prize or become the
dictator of a nation in the Pacific
Islands or contract terminal ear cancer
or spontaneously combust but if you
consider all the unlikely things
together at least one of them will
probably happen to each of us I could
have seen it rain frogs I could have
stepped foot on Mars I could have been
eaten by a whale I could have married
the Queen of England or survived months
at sea but my miracle was different my
miracle was this out of all the houses
in all the subdivisions in all of
Florida I ended up living next door to
Margo Roth Spiegelman our subdivision
Jefferson Park used to be a Navy base
but then the Navy didn't need it anymore
so it returned the land to the citizens
of Orlando Florida who decided to build
a massive subdivision because that's
what Florida does would land my parents
and Margo's parents ended up moving next
door to one another just after the first
houses were built Margo and I were two
before Jefferson Park was a
Pleasantville and before it was a Navy
base it belonged to an act
to Jefferson this guy dr. Jefferson
Jefferson dr. Jefferson Jefferson has a
school named after him in Orlando and
also a large Charitable Foundation but
the fascinating and unbelievable but
true thing about dr. Jefferson Jefferson
is that he was not a doctor of any kind
he was just an orange juice salesman
named Jefferson Jefferson when he became
rich and powerful he went to court made
Jefferson his middle name and then
changed his first name to doctor capital
D lowercase R period Margo and I were
nine our parents were friends so we
would sometimes play together biking
past the cul-de-sac streets to Jefferson
Park itself the hub of our subdivisions
wheel
I always got very nervous whenever I've
heard that Margo was about to show up on
account of how she was the most
fantastically gorgeous creature that God
had ever created on the morning in
question
she wore white shorts and a pink t-shirt
that featured a green dragon breathing a
fire of orange glitter it is difficult
to explain how awesome I found this
t-shirt at the time Margo has always
biked standing up her arms locked as she
leaned above the handlebars her purple
sneakers a circuitous blur it was a
steam hot day in March the sky was clear
but the air tasted acidic like it might
storm later at the time I fancied myself
an inventor and after we locked up our
bikes and began the short walk across
the park to the playground
I told Margo about an idea I had for an
invention called the ring later the ring
out later was this gigantic cannon that
would shoot big colored rocks into a
very low orbit giving earth the same
sort of rings that Saturn has I still
think this would be a fine idea
but it turns out that building a cannon
that can shoot boulders into a low orbit
is fairly complicated I've been in this
park so many times before that it was
mapped in my mind so we were only a few
steps inside when I began to sense that
the world was out of order even though I
couldn't immediately figure out what was
different
Quentin Margo said quietly calmly she
was pointing and then I realized what
was different he was encircled by blood
a half-dried fountain of it poured out
of his mouth the mouth open in a way
that mouths generally shouldn't be flies
at rest on his pale forehead he's dead
Margo said as if I couldn't tell I took
two small steps backward I remember
thinking that if I may
any sudden movements he might wake up
and attack me maybe he was a zombie I
mean I knew zombies weren't real but he
sure looked like a potential zombie as I
took those two steps back
Margo took two equally small and quiet
steps forward his eyes are open
she said we got to go home I said I
thought you closed your eyes when you
died she said Margo we got to go home
and tell she took another step she was
close enough now to reach out and touch
his foot what do you think happened to
him she asked maybe it was drugs or
something I didn't want to leave Margo
alone with the dead guy who might be an
attack zombie but I also didn't care to
stand around and chat about the
circumstances of his demise I gathered
my courage and stepped forward to take
her hand
Margo we gotta go right now we ran to
our bikes my stomach churning with
something that felt exactly like
excitement but wasn't we got on our
bikes and I let her go in front of me
because I was crying and didn't want her
to see I could see blood on the soles of
her purple sneakers his blood the dead
guy blood and then we were back home in
our separate houses my parents called
911 and I heard the sirens in the
distance and asked to see the fire
trucks but my mom said no then I took a
nap both my parents are therapists which
means that I'm really gone damned well
adjusted so when I woke up I had a long
conversation with my mom about the cycle
of life and how death is a part of life
but not a part of life I needed to be
particularly concerned about at the age
of nine and I felt better honestly I
never worried about it much which is
saying something because I can do some
worrying here's the thing I found a dead
guy little adorable nine year old me and
my even littler and more adorable
playdate found a guy with blood pouring
out of his mouth and that blood was on
her little adorable sneakers as we biked
home it's all very dramatic and
everything but so what I didn't know the
guy people I don't know died all the
damn time if I had a nervous breakdown
every time something awful happened in
the world I'd be crazy that night I went
into my room at nine o'clock to go to
bed because nine o'clock was my bedtime
my mom tucked me in told me she loved me
and I said see you tomorrow and she said
see you tomorrow and then she turned out
the lights and closed the door almost
all the way as I turned on my side I saw
Margo Roth Spiegelman standing outside
my window her face almost pressed
against the screen I got up and opened
the window but the screen stayed between
us pixellating her
I did an investigation she said quite
seriously even up close the screen broke
her face apart but I could tell that she
was holding a little notebook and a
pencil with teeth marks around the
eraser she glanced down at her notes
mrs. Feldman from over on Jefferson
Court said his name was Robert Joyner
she told me he lived on Jefferson Road
in one of those little condos on top of
the grocery store so I went over there
and there were a bunch of policemen and
one of them asked me if I worked at the
school paper and I said our school
didn't have a paper and he said as long
as I wasn't a journalist you would
answer my questions he said Robert
Joyner was 36 years old a lawyer they
wouldn't let me in the apartment but a
lady and Juanita Alvarez lives next door
to him and I got into her apartment by
asking if I could borrow a cup of sugar
and then she said that Robert Joyner had
killed himself with a gun and then I
asked why and then she told me that he
was getting a divorce and he was sad
about it
she stopped them and I just looked at
her her face gray and moonlit and split
into a thousand little pieces by the
weave of the window screen her wide
round eyes flitted back and forth from
her notebook to me lots of people get
divorces and don't kill themselves I
said I know she said that's what I told
Juanita Alvarez and then she said Marva
flipped the notebook page
she said that mr. Joyner was troubled
and then I asked what that meant and
then she told me that we should just
pray for him and that I needed to take
the sugar to my mom and I said forget
the sugar and left
I said nothing again I just wanted her
to keep talking that small voice tense
with the excitement of almost knowing
things making me feel like something
important was happening to me I think I
maybe know why she said finally why
maybe all the strings inside him broke
she said well I tried to think of
something to say an answer to that
I reached forward and press the lock on
the screen between us dislodging it from
the window I placed the screen on the
floor but she didn't give me a chance to
speak before I could sit back down
she just raised her face up toward me
and whispered shut the window so I did I
thought she would leave but she just
stood there watching me I waved at her
and smiled but her eyes seemed fixed on
something behind me something monstrous
that had already drained the blood from
her face and I felt too afraid to turn
around to see but there was nothing
behind me of course I stopped waving my
head was level with hers as we stared at
each other from opposite sides of the
glass I don't remember how it ended if I
went to bed or she did in my memory it
and we just stay there looking at each
other forever
Margo always loved mysteries and in
everything that came afterward I could
never stop thinking that maybe she loved
mysteries so much that she became one so
that's the prologue and then we start
with part 1 which is called the strings
nerdfighters thank you thank you for
being awesome
Hank travel safe and I'll see you
tomorrow